نعم ليلى قبل قليل سمعنا دوي اطلاقات
ناريه كثيفه يبدو انها ناجمه عن اشتباكات
بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في منطقه البلد وسط مدينه
خانيونس الى جانب سماع دوي انفجارين
كبيرين في منطقه الزنه وايضا في محيط
منطقه القراره الى الشمال الشرقي من مدينه
خانيونس وسط تحليق مكثف للطائرات الحربيه
وايضا لطائرات الاستطلاع على ارتفاعات
منخفضه في مختلف المناطق كما تدور
اشتباكات في منطقه قيزان النجار ومحيط
منطقه بطن السمين الى الجنوب الشرقي من
المدينه وتقوم المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
باطلاق عدد من القذائف الصاروخيه تجاه
منازل مواطنين وايضا الاراضي الزراعيه في
المحور الجنوبي الشرقي من المدينه وسط
ايضا اطلاقات ناريه كثيفه من الدبابات
والاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه ايض ايضا الطيران
الحربي الاسرائيلي شن سلسله من الغارات
العنيفه في محيط المستشفى الاوروبي القريب
من منطقه قيزان النجار ومنطقه معن التان
تشهدان اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه كما شهدنا
اليوم استخدام القناصه الاسرائيليين اطلاق
عيارات ناريه اجاه عدد من المواطنين
والنازحين في محيط مستشفى الامل في حي
الامل الى الشمال الشرقي من مدينه خان
يونس هذه المنطقه ومحيطها تشهد ا شباكات
مسلحه عنيفه بين المقاومه تحديدا بعد
اعاده توغلها الى شارع خمسه وايضا محيط
منطقه القراره بالاضافه الى شارع القسام
المؤدي الى منطقه البلد وسط مدينه خان
يونس في وسط القطاع تستمر المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه في اطلاق قذائفها الصاروخيه
اتجاه الاطراف الشرقيه والشماليه من مخيمي
المغازي والبريج بالاضافه الى قصف مدفعي
يشهده شمال مخيم النصيرات سبقها غاره
اسرائيليه استهدفت منزلا في منطقه المحكمه
القديمه في جباليا ادت هذه الغاره التي
استهدفت المنزل الماهول بالسكان الى
استشهاد خمسه من الفلسطينيين واصابه
العشرات بجروح متفاوته تحديدا في المنطقه
الشماليه الجرحى على وجه التحديد لا يجدون
سيارات اسعاف تنقلهم الى المشافي وايضا
جميع المشافي في المنطقه الشماليه خرجت عن
الخدمه ينتظرون لساعات الصباح الباكر ومن
يتمكن ان ينقلهم سواء عبر سيارات مدنيه او
وسائل نقل بدائيه الى مدينه غزه لتلقي
العلاج في المستشفى المعمداني وهو المشفى
الوحيد الذي يعمل ويخدم المنطقه الشماليه
ومدينه غزه بعد اخراج قوات الاحتلال اكثر
من 30 مستشفى عن الخدمه في عموم القطاع